>> Tucker: THE SOVIET BLOC
COLLAPSED NEARLY 30 YEARS AGO
BUT LIVES ON NEW YORK COLLEGE
CAMPUS.
MORE THAN 200 SCHOOLS MAINTAIN
WHAT THEY CALLED BIAS AND
RESPONSE TEAMS.
THEIR JOB IS TO INVESTIGATE
THOUGHT CRIMES THE STUDENTS MAY
HAVE COMMITTED.
UNIVERSITY OF MICHIGAN, STUDENTS
ARE URGED TO SPY ON THEIR PEERS
AND MAKE ANONYMOUS REPORTS IF
THEY SEE OR HEAR ANYONE USING
THE WRONG WORDS OR THINKING
UNAPPROVED THOUGHTS.
THE SCHOOL IS BEING SUED BY
ADVOCATES FOR THE
FIRST AMENDMENT WHO POINT OUT
THAT CREEPY THOUGHT POLICE
PROBABLY VIOLATE THE
FIRST AMENDMENT.
PRESIDENT OF SPEECH FIRST WHICH
BROUGHT THAT LAWSUIT, JOINS US
TONIGHT TO EXPLAIN IT.
THAT I OVERSTATE THAT?
BIAS RESPONSE TEAM [BOOS]
FACE WILL POPPED UP
THE --
>> YOU CAN REPORT SPEECH.
NOT EVEN THAT YOU HAVE BEEN
SUBJECT TO, BUT THAT YOU'VE
OVERHEARD.
MAYBE WHAT YOU AND I ARE HAVING
A CONVERSATION ABOUT THE TV
SHOW.
SOMEBODY WALKS BY OUR WALKING BY
AND THEY THINK I DON'T LIKE THAT
WORD AND WE WILL BE BROUGHT
BEFORE THE BIAS RESPONSE TEAMS
AND WE WILL HAVE TO EXPLAIN
OURSELVES.
>> Tucker: YOU HAVE TO TALK TO
THE POLICE IF SOMEONE REPORTS
YOU FOR SAYING SOMETHING
UNAPPROVED.
SO WHAT IF YOU SAY I'M NOT
INTERESTED IN THIS KIND OF THING
AND I DON'T WANT TO TALK TO YOU
AND BUZZ OFF?
>> YOU WILL BE SUBJECT TO
PUNISHMENTS, WHICH MIGHT INCLUDE
REMEDIATION, THEY CALL IT
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE, YOU MIGHT
HAVE TO GO TO CULTURAL
APPROPRIATION TRAINING OR SOME
OTHER KIND OF DIVERSITY
UNCONSCIOUS BIAS TRAINING WHICH
I HEAR IS A THING THESE DAYS.
I CAN GO UP TO AND INCLUDE
EXPULSION DEPENDING ON HOW
SEVERE YOUR TRANSGRESSION WAS.
>> Tucker: SEE YOU HAVE NO
POWER?
>> YOU HAVE NO POWER.
>> Tucker: HAS ANYONE BEFORE
YOU POINTED OUT THAT YOU HAVE AN
ABSOLUTE RIGHT GUARANTEED IN THE
FIRST ITEM IN THE BILL OF RIGHTS
TO SAY WHAT YOU THINK IS TRUE,
PERIOD?
>> THERE'VE BEEN A LOT OF PEOPLE
WHO HAVE WRITTEN ABOUT IT, THE
FOUNDATION HAS DONE INCREDIBLE
WORK.
>> Tucker: WHAT ABOUT THE A
ACLU?
>> THEY HAVEN'T WAITED ON THIS.
>> Tucker: I THOUGHT THEY CARE
ABOUT FREE SPEECH THOUGH?
>> DAVIS STEPPED BACK ON THAT
RECENTLY.
WE DECIDED TO BRING A LAWSUIT.
LET'S DRAW A LINE IN THE SAND.
WE ARE A MEMBERSHIP ASSOCIATION
SO WE HAVE THREE STUDENTS ON THE
UNIVERSITY OF MICHIGAN ON THE
CAMPUS WHO HAVE ENROLLED WHO
HAVE DECIDED LET'S PUSHED BACK.
WE WILL BE REPRESENTING THEM AS
OUR ASSOCIATION BECAUSE THEY ARE
SCARED, WITH GOOD REASON.
THEY DON'T WANT THEIR NAMES OUT
THERE.
>> Tucker: WHAT IS THE
UNIVERSITY 'S POSITION ON THIS?
IT DOESN'T COVER COLLEGE
CAMPUSES OR DO THEY HAVE AN
ARGUMENT?
>> THEY HAVEN'T RESPONDED TO US
YET.
WE WILL BE FILING FOR A
PRELIMINARY INJUNCTION.
WE HOPE TO HALT ON THE PROGRAMS
UNTIL WE CAN COME TO THE
CONCLUSION WHETHER RIGHTS ARE
RESPECTED.
>> Tucker: DID YOU PUT THE
UNIVERSITY OUT OF BUSINESS AND
MAKE SURE IT NEVER RISES AGAIN
FROM THE ASHES?
>> AS YOU SAID BEFORE THERE ARE
OVER 200 SCHOOLS THAT HAVE
PROGRAMS LIKE THIS.
>> Tucker: I HOPE YOU CRUSH
THEM ALL BECAUSE THIS IS A
THREAT TO EVERYTHING THAT WE